Andrew Tay has been arrested but the  official narrative makes no sense they  say that Police use a videotape posted  on his Twitter with a pizza box that  belonged to a local Romanian Pizza chain  to confirm that he was indeed in Romania  before raiding his place and arresting  him but everyone knows Tate lives in  Romania everyone knows he's got a giant  compound there girls all over Romania go  to his compound he's bragged about  Romania all the time online why would  police need a pizza box to confirm that  he's actually there when they could have  just looked for themselves they  obviously knew where his place was and  yet they waited to raid him the day  after he calls off one of the greatest  heroes of the Matrix Greta thundberg  strange timing right but there's even  more to the story that doesn't make  sense so subscribe for part 2 because